just give me a sec well I you know was
added to the list it's not even my fault
because who know was added wait wait
before we haven't played it in years I
have not played this beautiful it 11
years there we go here we go and I'm
joining now here we go wait for it three
two one I'm in mine crash the game so
long then come out with uno 2.0 I've
been waiting for you dance is this
you're welcome I can't hear anything
oh there we go I wasn't ready okay
alright that's just rude oh god I forgot
you could jump in yeah it's your turn
just dance yeah yeah [ __ ] you I don't
know what that means I just went for it
that means if they had a blue card you
would have won the challenge and
they would have had to take dude it
hasn't been so long but you can't have
completely forgotten how to play for
example Bob you made it red right mark
has a red she has to draw of cards
because I challenged he does not
therefore I'll draw six there you go you
think I'm a lying [ __ ] you're a
lying [ __ ] I did it one because
I don't trust you two to show Bob how it
works at three because I don't trust you
listen I think looking I have an idea
yeah no no no actually I have another
idea
I don't know why I did that that wasn't
very useful I don't know why either it
was a good move it was a good move I
think aha hey it's me I'm on the card
that's me
thanks to you thank you Bob I
I got options yeah there's lots of fun
well that's pretty [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] god
dammit you can also just click the cards
you don't have to press the button I was
pushing W the frantically oh why is it
called a speeding why I get skip oh
that's pretty good I don't understand
this god dammit [ __ ] you guys
dickholes [ __ ] yeah do you Bob what did
I do
alright this isn't actually an
improvement for me but it's just it's an
improvement fine
oh hey I like this you know it baby
got him that's a nice double play look
you think that's gonna throw me no you
unless you think that's gonna yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah wait whoa oh yeah right
what the [ __ ] no I I clicked on it no no
wait no hang on no I clicked uno I heard
it say you know before I click the
exclamation point whatever it's fine
it's fine what is my click what the [ __ ]
I don't know how Isis what the hell
mark Stern I don't know the [ __ ] is
happening
I don't know no it was not funny that's
what it wasn't was wait that's why it
was it was what it was and was what is
this was yeah they tried to security
tried to screw me but you screwed
screwed then not now they screwed me I
screw it yeah have a sexy carrot [ __ ]
that's ok I got a dancing man ooh nice
red that's a nice red here go mark you
can pass it forward for seven you fool
oops I'll take
mine back give me that probably good
call all right you play good play good
play boys I got him well what do you got
uh I don't think that's gonna fool me
Oh No oh dear that's bad
ha ha caught him oh [ __ ] what their hand
on what yours good what's wrong with
mine I mean what's good about mine sure
everyone's spaceship [ __ ] everyone
that's a good for everybody
right I got [ __ ] oh yeah you got
[ __ ] oh here comes a [ __ ] you would do
the same heartbeat do anything to you
you've done plenty to me my goodness you
are a dill okay I think we can all agree
that the computers the real douche here
oh no no no no oh just what color they
pick find that one walk I wish there was
a way to pass this along but I'm just
outraged so no man come on come on come
on man come on man oh yeah got him all
right that's all Oh God you made it
thank you for challenging marks now that
it's red I'm going to draw a little bit
no I don't it was good it was not good
no come on
here we go ready here we hate all of you
a garden gnome style guy let's play it
that's not gonna be okay
five is Gangnam style I thought I was
gonna get that don't blame me I didn't
get that oh wait that was my end I did
not hear hey what have you done to it I
didn't do anything you think uno high
it's [ __ ] Christmas experiment
rubbish oh yeah play would play I hate
you
Yanni blues over there wait es Weird Al
wait so what color no I can okay I can
yeah I don't know what what what
anything other than a number draw a card
if they have blue I swear to God thank
you better than you guys winning at
least
is it watery and yet this round and then
all over that action yeah say him you
fool you can fool no I [ __ ] hate
y'all [ __ ] the long slow delve into
the realizations wait why you computer
[Laughter]
[Music]
you do you learning some weight so what
are you where do you click to call the
computer on uno because it's about to be
at UNO and [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] have it
alright let's jump in [ __ ] thank you
thank you thank you well now they don't
have green it's fine it's fine
oh oh oh no what does that hands that
means we're all down to two cards oh
[ __ ]
no no oh [ __ ]
well I'm really sorry mark you know what
so sad so sad you know it's so sad no
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you know what
that's fine I'm whatever this is I
didn't get all of you and you play
anything but a number you draw oh [ __ ]
me how do you know it looks like you
have two cards where do I talk to you do
I still draw oh my god Hey
all of you I hate you why did you give
him a good hand why did you do it I
didn't want you to win why should you
win Bob because I've never won I don't
want anything today I don't even [ __ ]
get my bait on the hook all right that's
for catch a fish that's fair that's fair
that's fair
no no one cares wait oh oh I'm real
sorry about this buddy whoa listen okay
listen buddy buddy I'm real sorry about
that buddy
I hate all of you in this entire game so
much no I don't oh come on Bob man I'm
happy Fred wait how good your hand oh
great great I mean great I mean great I
just have to play the game to be here
Wade I choose this one Wow okay Molly
brought me food oh that's so no no no
[ __ ] whatever that much I didn't do
that the computer did that thank you
why did you have a shitty hand you
should have known - my entire [ __ ]
life doll here's some more for your life
that's my draw - that I was saving but I
didn't play against you on purpose
okay I believe that wait if you win it
place wait wait listen let's talk about
this oh wow I say what you did there's a
problem with that hand if you're trying
to win stuff you can always save that
card for last I don't even I have been
paying attentions I'm trying so hard my
food don't eat food I'm not yet mark
take some time to stew on it it's all
guy at this point all I've got
nobody insult my turn do it again
okay there's lots of good stuff [ __ ]
there's no way you don't have yellow
know these extra cards are weird as shop
I'm [ __ ] I guess it wasn't for him if
he was drawing right wait no I'm not a
fool in that no maybe I'm not a fool no
this one oh yeah yeah boy man that's
really that's just rough huh yeah real
rough
[Laughter]
there we go okay all right no no is that
good did I do good what is what is this
what is happening what's happening what
happened oh it's not oh it's not a oh
it's not a it wasn't a number card
that's right forgot about that
oh wait so is that the whole time now it
goes yeah oh god but not so fast I've
screwed myself up because I just draw I
just I see something flashing I'm like I
should put the bottom there ha sure I
saw that and then I do it is a good
sequence I love it other people look
wait I've got it kind of good stuff
[Music]
what does that do I was doing fine I was
doing fine I was doing fine I was doing
fine it doesn't matter here also had
three cards that was probably better
don't care I just really want to click
on stuff I miss clicking on stuff guys
do you remember when I used to play do
stuff you remember ow
I don't know actually I used to do so
many stuff just good just good just good
just so just good stuff yeah good stuff
Wow good play Bob good play good play
Bob good play I got him again that's a
good play that's a good why are you
gonna change the color like that if you
want me to help you
never mind got one was that a good bit
too felt like the good bit okay wait
what the [ __ ] it's all I can do
[ __ ] let's give me something that makes
weight said mark help me no why would
that doesn't help me just not that my
third win in a row I need it guys know
it just like you immensely no mark look
it's fine see thank God
see it's fine [ __ ] it's okay look at
this wait so long as everyone's unhappy
I got four of them I'm good what above
and beyond look look guys it's like golf
the more you get the better right it is
fun to have a lot of cards and to drop
some D's on some people already fun
pretty fun haha that's my turn no it's
not oh there's a problem here well
take mine me I guess that's fine I know
what's gonna happen now yeah that's the
stuff that's good damn it
wait please zero for God's sake please
here I draw think about it think about
it think about it now you're a fool who
knows just played with like normal cards
that don't do weird amazing things let
me like why this I'm not gonna have this
for a while take it right from me I'm
gonna lose this it's gonna be gone your
hand wait this is qts fault your hand oh
god are we going literally made that
happen oh good I get to go first
good it's fun stuff do it wait it's a
good handball I didn't really want get
rid of oh no all right is a good hand I
just wanted to check it for you Bob on
to make sure it was really good a little
confirmation on what's going on in there
that's quality stuff it's good stuff
right right oh yeah
- you have like six cards like six card
draw - like this one
oh well that's kind of rude how do you
not have a draw to bow before I only had
four cards [ __ ] wait no one [ __ ] with it
no one [ __ ] with it I have a draw for I
mark okay fine I dropped my draw for was
the blue don't worry they don't know
they don't know
wow they took it stupid problematic card
in all of these hands see this is where
you goofed I don't know what to do here
Bob the cards the fate of the cards the
cards wait orga cards yes thank you so
much I'd like to thank all my fans you
really brought me here I thank everyone
for supporting me all these years
finally I click a [ __ ] card
haha oh god are we going again I've got
good stuff alright we'll play this game
out it's gonna be a two-hour game here
whose turn is it
oh it's waste Ernie's baubles may take
his hands I don't really have that good
stuff but you're welcome or whatever
well you had good stuff I know
cacao Wow oh no no no no no no no was
gonna do it again it's awfully tame game
so far okay whoa damn still tame still
very tail okay okay to calm the [ __ ]
down buddy
pow what's up pal good friend he's just
gonna just gonna be like that yeah man
did you get drunk in the last two
seconds I didn't want to do this what is
this we all are down to some yards
we're done three well not really
[Laughter]
textbook
YouTube YouTube overreaction Oh ali-a
playing some uno holy [ __ ] sorry
sick burn there Bob got'em you really
got him oh well hey listen I think you
might be goofing me I think there's ever
a situation where you're goofing me I
think it would be now because at least
[Laughter]
we're friends Oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what the
hell okay
wait there's a thing I should do here
yeah do 90% sure it's that good guys I
figure out my last part no how do you
not Jesus Christ
yes okay oh you can tell you bud okay
let's just kill it
oh yeah come on wait bring it home I lit
on and pile it on him wait Oh dirty girl
now that's right
[ __ ] me in the ear holes what oh hey
listen I'm just gonna do this
[Laughter]
no no no okay I don't even have a good
hand I thought I had a good answer that
[ __ ] I keep losing my all just hear it
listen it's fine just why is that good
it's blue good for you bye
oh wait wait hang on that's an option oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
come on no it's okay please
[Applause]
come on there all right
what's a good color mark oh it's gonna
be good that's good that's good that's
what I want you sure you don't want a
[ __ ] reverse it nah man why no that's
not what I want no no I have the next
few cards oh [ __ ] oh god wait no wait no
I have nothing but not those cards I'll
just leave it one color for like not the
same color I know I know matter what I
have to draw yes
you're welcome everybody else wait your
turn no no no no no no no no no
we should hit the Harley I don't know
what you want and I probably picked
wrong and I've got [ __ ] but no this
just went downhill quickly when you draw
a card me about this disco thing is such
[ __ ] alright somebody [ __ ]
reverse this [ __ ] please no no don't do
it okay don't go reverse it donors
[Music]
oh you [ __ ]
Wow goddamn Savage do anything he's just
been over there having a good time how
do you have so many of those hey how's
it feel I took your hand once I took you
around once and I was it there's no way
there's no way yeah you had rats you
[ __ ] a hole right you [ __ ] you
unbelievable [ __ ] oh the city shitty
[ __ ] bang bang is wrong with you I
just play the game man hate the play
what the shitty shitty [ __ ] gang bang
is wrong with ya
oh my god it's over it's over it's
finally over
just Canada how do I quit this game
there we go
part of the cards guys hardly carts are
to the card the card to the cards part
of the cards are the cards
[Music]